bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
kiosque tout de suite le sommaire de ce
mercredi 27 avril
mais qui est il sous son chapeau un
monde habité par une douce folie où
l'absurde et l'étrange transcende le
quotidien redouanne harjane est en
plateau avec nous et sera la royale
factory de versailles les 29 30 avril et
6 et 7 mai prochains
lydia martinico originaire de la vallée
de chevreuse et en plateau pour nous
présenter son deuxième album d'une
étoile à l'autre un album éclectique
pour rendre hommage à ses mentors
musicaux et ses racines italiennes
nicolas sanhes artiste sculpteur
installé à saint quentin en yvelines
depuis 1997 nous rejoindra dans quelques
instants avec lui nous évoquerons la
visite de son atelier prévu samedi 30
avril et nous commençons donc cette
émission avec un plateau d'artistes
mélomanes on démarre avec vous redouanne
harjane alors votre singularité
artistique c'est d'être à la fois
humoriste et musiciens et tout au long
de votre parcours vous avez toujours
mêlés comme ça le théâtre la musique du
théâtre au collège
vous démarrez avec la musique au lycée
ensuite les cours simon et vous
souhaitez intégrer dans vos spectacles
la musique et le théâtre job une raison
particulière de ne pas avoir souhaité
trancher choisir entre les deux déjà
bonjour merci de me recevoir
navré de passer avant vous
madame c'est vrai car il la galère une
heure disons que
ou en fait j'ai commencé par le théâtre
après j'ai eu la chance de découvrir la
musique je suis revenu impôt théâtre je
suis revenue au thé à la musique
et puis j'ai pas mangé pas voulu
abandonner là on profite de l'autre puis
même au fur et à mesure que je me suis
trouvée l'envi décrire l envie de
défendre des choses humoristique que
j'ai réalisé que l'humour c'était déjà
très musical en fait il ya une rythmique
il ya une rihanna rythme est très
musical dans l'humour voila voila je
sais très bien parler de ce que je fais
c'est parce qu'il est un peu un peu
perché j'aime bien les gens que ça va
être un plat chaud dynamique alors vous
démarrez avec des scènes ouvertes très
ouverte même souvent que vos débuts dans
le cas dans des clubs libertins
on reste dans la rue puis arrive le
jamel comedy club pendant six ans et
c'est jamal d'ailleurs qui va produire
votre premier spectacle dans la tête de
rideau en argent d'ailleurs il ya c'est
à la fois texte piano et guitare alors
justement dans ce spectacle on retrouve
ce personnage aussi un peu décalé dans
le nouveau spectacle
ce personnage c'est qui c'est vous c'est
un rôle de composition
c'est moi et puis c'est un peu tout le
monde j'ai envie de dire c'est un
personnage qui s'approprie qu'ils
s'approprient les mots les maux de notre
société
les malaises les mal être et puis
en fait beaucoup au début beaucoup de
gens me disaient mais c'est un fou ce
personnage les fous et en fait j'ai
envie de dire presque non il s'est le
plus sensé c'est lui qui sait lui qui
face à la folie du monde tente de rester
le plus sensé et d'avoir un regard
d'essayer d'être plus lucide possible en
fait c'est pas un spectacle drôle mais
non si si mais je veux dire mon
personnage cherché à être drôle cherche
à faire rire sur des sujets qui ne le
sont pas forcément quoi un peu comme
lorsque mes influences les références un
peu comme chaplin keaton chaplin ctd
c'est la plupart de ces films sont
sociales quoi choisir pour inciter à la
réflexion c'est pour dénoncer quelque
chose dénoncer non parce que dénoncé il
ya un côté où c'est là bas que ça se
passe et puis on n'est pas on n'est pas
on n'est pas dans la moi je fais sinon
mais surtout que je fais je suis je suis
un citoyen je fais partie de ce monde je
ne peux pas faire comme si je vivais
dans une dans une forêt et que je
regardais les choses de loin comme un
philosophe qui saura ni un livre qui pas
non je suis dans l'époque je suis dans
mon époque je suis le fruit de mon
époque et maintenant je fais de l'humour
je fais du one man et je parle de ça je
veux faire rire intelligemment
vous êtes très sensibles à l'absurde
d'ailleurs c'est souvent le terme qui
revient pour qualifier votre spectacle
votre personnage et vous dites
d'ailleurs je ne trouve de réalité qu'à
partir de choses absurdes cas parler de
choses absurdes et en effet je sais pas
si c'est très absurde de dire que j'aime
l'absurde l'absurde mais en effet passé
ça j'aime bouger mme beaucoup l'absurde
j'aime j'aime le jem la gymnastique de
l'esprit se prendre la tête
un peu comme lorsque le beckett en
attendant godot
est ce que la réalité existe vraiment ou
alors est-ce que ce qu'on vit est ce que
c'est ce qu'on se doit de vivre
est ce que il n'ya pas une porte
derrière la porte alors on va juste voir
ce que vous entendez pas absurde avec un
premier extrait sur le cheval extrait
donc de votre ou vos spectacles pièces
ont déjà vu un homme portait des queues
de cheval
en jeu les vul un cheval porter une
poudre
des sites historiques ans
il s'en fout si les gardiens ou cowboys
de cheval alors qu'est ce qui peut vous
inspirer comme ça sur le thème du cheval
être achevé à la place d'un homme un peu
comme ce que faisait je sais pas par
exemple dans la fontaine on prend des
animaux et on leur fait vivre des
histoires et on a l'impression que l'on
léon les humanise on peut dire plein de
choses enfin la fontaine arrivé à dire à
dire énormément de choses de façon
sociétal même si c'est à la base des
trucs pour le dauphin ça tombe bien
juste qu'on est en plein dans
d'improbables à versailles mais on peut
dire des choses on peut on peut dire des
choses
très très on peut déguiser un discours
en parlant des animaux en temps en tout
cas en prenant en premier rôle un animal
médias martinico l'humour par l'absurde
ça vous parle avant que j'adore se prend
enfin cesser faire des choses il fait
des choses je ne connais pas bien mais
je le vois quand même de temps en temps
il fait des choses sérieuses sont se
prendre au sérieux il dit des choses qui
sont assez vrai et par le biais de
l'absurde et c'est vraiment ce qui est à
mon sens pour l'humour le plus le plus
important les choses qui sont ras de
terre mais ça me convient pas mais il a
du talent ce garçon alors vous arrivez
donc tout juste avec ce deuxième
spectacle qui n'a pas encore de nom
il est baptisé une nouveau spectacle
redouanne harjane comme ça au moins pas
trop de prise de risque on ne va pas se
priver d'un deuxième extrait celui-ci
s'intitule seul dans mon monde
pourquoi est ce que tous les trains les
fauteuils en accueille dans le sens
inverse
c'est pourquoi
pourquoi comment tout le mois
est ce qu'un médecin qui fait une
autopsie sur une femme enceinte où il
est payé le double seulement voilà
comment mais plusieurs dans votre tête
non mais c'est ça oui ça dépend de
l'ordonance sorte un peu schizophrène
les fois dans cette société
la société est schizophrène est
schizophrénique
c'est ce que je vous disais au début
cette interview c'est que mon personnage
n'est pas fou il
les spectateurs de la folie on la france
est le premier pays consommateur de
psychotropes
c'est la société qui va mal c'est notre
société qui souffrent ou non il est pas
foulé pas schizophrène hic mais par
contre c'est que il sait que le 17 le
mans de tombes par an ça c'est clair
c'est donc un spectacle musical
humoristique avec lequel vous revenez
vous allez partir en tournée en tournée
internationale
on pourra vous retrouverez un collier
mais avant singapour en tout cas à la
royale factory les 29 et 30 avril
prochains 6 et 7 mai donc de week end
vendredi samedi vendredi et samedi deux
week-ends explosif je pense qui
s'annonce avec vous les gens ne
s'ennuieront pas et vous serez également
les 27 et 28 mai prochain au café de la
danse à paris à l'apa paris la capitale
paris la capitale de la france et on
pourra vous retrouvez également bientôt
dans m votre premier rôle dans un long
métrage long métrage de sara forestier
premier premier grand rôle j'imagine
c'est comme ça qu'on dit je crois dans
le jargon cinématographique mais pour
l'instant rien n'est là l'expérience a
été l'expérience a été fait on se dit
c'est tellement blanc ici
ouais l'expérience était fait c'était
assez intense grosse préparation
physique puis pepy psychologie les
muscles ouais c'est ça ouais ça pulse et
ça d'accord vous souhaitez redouane pour
la suite de votre parcours artistique du
beau on se souhaite à tous du boom pow
pour l'artistique je pense qu'il faut du
beau et puis il faut être il faut rester
vaillance et masculine de ce qui nous
arrive là donc la santé du bo alors
quelqu'un qui partage sa philosophie
également c'est lydia martinico l'idée
martinique au café elle est musicienne
les auteurs compositeurs interprètes
alors vous aurez le fener de chez nous
vous êtes né à saint cyr l'école
exactement on descend bien sûr vous avez
grandi dans la vallée de chevreuse mais
vous avez on ne l'oublient pas une
double culture
je serai encore nationale italienne très
enlevant plusieurs à être bi national
alors que nous concédons de nouasseur on
est plusieurs succès ça sur la faute
c'est ça vous votre instrument de
prédilection c'est le piège le piano
vous avez d'ailleurs étudié au
conservatoire
quant aux faits et puis un moment
marquant ou alors vous avez travaillé
avec sacha distel d'autres grands
musiciens puis à un moment marquant dans
votre dans votre parcours c'est une
rencontre on voit tout de suite écoutez
un extrait de votre nouvel album
syracuse et en eau par la presse cette
rencontre
les lotos pack caire au vent
et l'écran soit 115 samu
alors c'est un cul c'est l'une des
quatre reprises que vous proposez sur
votre dernier album qui vient de sortir
qu'ils appellent d'une étoile à l'autre
et je voulais bien sûr parler de votre
rencontre avec henri salvador
monsieur seulement qu'est ce que ça a
changé pour vous cette rencontre ça
change et ça a tout changé en fait
j'étais musicienne avec les uns avec les
autres comme beaucoup de musiciens ou
certaines séances de voix également et
j'ai rencontré henri salvador à l'époque
de chambre avec vues ce magnifique
succès que tout le monde connaît en
préparer l'album
et puis quand il quand est arrivée la
tournée le premier spectacle était au
châtelet a prévenu alain pia on lui a
dit voilà il faudra une fille au clavier
ce qui est des cordes devant faudrait
une fille au clavier qui double tout ça
et puis qui met un peu d'ambiance
est-ce que martinico ça tirait il a dit
oui tout de suite parce qu'ils avaient
un souvenir de moi en studio très
sympathique
donc du coup on est devenus les
meilleurs amis du monde alors c'est une
aventure qui a duré dix ans oui de
tournée mondiale vous l'avez dit donc
pour à singapour mais tokyo ça me semble
avec vue puis vous avez également été
parolière pour lui et oui ça change tout
à fait ma chère et tendre bonsoir amis
et surtout le dernier aussi révérence je
vais la chance d'écrire pour henry alors
ça c'est un moment fabuleux parce que
quand on est un monsieur comme ça qu'il
ya eu quand même les plus grands auteurs
et qui vous demande une chanson séjour
de chambre avec vues avec karen non mais
surtout on avait vu avec keren ann moi
j'ai commencé à te faire les les
chansons avec lui sur les albums sur un
suivi en fait voilà c'est canal violet
mais pas de chansons de gardanne et bio
les uns se chambre avec vues alors qu'on
se le dise que soit le 10
malheureusement ce grand homme nous a
quitté en 2008
et pour vous en fait ça a été un
déclencheur parce que de la et sorties a
pu naître votre premier album al dante
pour lequel vous avez d'ailleurs obtenu
un prix en italie le premio milliard est
martin le plus immédiat martini en fait
j'avais une chanson en italien
d'ailleurs que henry reconnaissait que
je m'amusais à jouer chez lui à saint
cyr sur mer dans le sud quand on est en
vacances et donc il me disait mais c'est
vachement bien
c'est vachement bien moi j'essaie ça
dans un coin parce que j'étais au
service de l'artiste
j'étais pas moins en train de me mettre
devant du tout donc je reste dans mon
coin tranquille et puis quand il est
décédé mes copains musiciens qui me
connaissent depuis qu'ils m'ont vu
débuter qui me connaissent depuis un bon
moment
m'ont appelé en me disant écoute tu
avais tu as dit je sens son italien
alors viens on est on rentre en studio
on fait un album et allons-y est en fête
avec cette chanson mal et vous avez vu
un extrait tout à l'heure alors on va
justement des pédants tout de suite un
extrait de mal
o'malley
s
non
mais
alors avec ce premier album on était sur
quelque chose d'assez pop rock et puis
on a complètement changé parce qu'avec
votre deuxième album donc d'une étoile à
l'autre on est sur quelque chose de
beaucoup plus éclectiques
oui il est vrai alors pop rock ce
qu'avec un extrait un extrait au piano
c'est vachement pop rock non mais c'est
vrai que ça fait un peu baladeur mais en
fait c'est parce que ses chansons ses
chansons italiennes le premier vraiment
de part je suis 75% italienne donc du
coup ses skis et sortir en premier donc
les textes en italien qui a fait ce
découpage en pourcentage c'est parce que
ma la des reprises
alors là sur le sol à l'album des
reprises parce que je ne voulais pas
faire un album en français sans rendre
hommage aux gens qui ont compté dans mon
parcours
sacha distel qui était enfin j'ai eu la
chance de travailler avec que des mecs
qui ont émigré six ans veut donc sacha
qui était un amour et j'ai vraiment on a
tellement passé de bons moments sur
scène entre face c'était formidable
et puis henry un énorme énorme tranche
de vie donc syracuse parce qu'il y avait
également un lien avec l'italie mon père
étant sicilien c'était un double un
double hommage
nicole croisille parce que nicole
croisille on chante ensemble une femme
avec toi en duo parce qu'une femme avec
toi qu'une chanson italienne au départ
de mire martini je la commence en
italien elle continue en français et
puis il ya le sud de nino ferrer parce
que j'avais rencontré monsieur n'est nos
frères j'ai dû tout petit avec un
chapeau comme ça il m'a vu vachement
impressionné et j'adore cette chanson et
c'est tout moi en fait c'est le côté sud
comme ça qui m'a pas mal et on a fait un
reggae et on est super enfin voila
c'était sont mes hommages et d'où une
étoile à l'autre voilà parce qu'on passe
aussi à des hommages à ma famille à une
amie qu'est parti enfin bref c'est un
joli voyage on me connaît mieux quand à
la sortie de l'album en fait donc quatre
reprises sur cet album mais également
des morceaux plus personnels comme
laisser une trace
où
mais l'élan
tous
classe
c'est une
alors on aborde toujours ces thèmes qui
sont au thème de prédilection le
déracinement parapluie non pas de son
papa tout et l'italie pour un secteur en
france
je peux te dire juste une chose
déracinés et laisser une trace sont deux
chansons que j'ai composées dont j'ai
composé la musique mais les textes sont
de claude lemesle claude lemesle étant
le grand parolier de bassins voilà qui a
fait de joe dassin qui a fait tous les
deux les ja ce qui a fait rédiger annick
voilà qui est un ancien président de la
sacem et tout est quelqu'un qui me kim a
parrainé mon niveau de la csn de
quelqu'un que je connais depuis très
longtemps qu'il m'a vu débuter vraiment
et j'ai appris l'écriture avec lui et
claude voilà accepté parce que c'était
des thèmes qui me touchait très
particulièrement déracinés pour mon père
je m'étais mise dans la tête mais qu'est
ce qu'est ce qui se passe dans la tête
d'un garçon qui a à peine 18 ans qui
arrive en france et qui laisse de côté
sa famille les artistes région oui moi
je viens de l'est de la france un
beaucoup d'italiens crise oui je sais je
sais gsm en fait suite à est arrivé là
parce qu'il a commencé
il est à révision à paris pour ses
études en fait et après le fait d'amour
et d'amitié
donc cet album il est sorti au début de
l'année il est dans les bacs on peut le
retrouver sur partout toutes les
plateformes de téléchargement il ya une
tournée bien sûr qui va s'ensuivre vous
serez le 7 mai au théâtre de l'européen
à paris est également en hausse 7 juin
bravo le 7 juin
pardon je vois qu'il ya déjà un bon dieu
qui est en train de se former peut-être
on vous retrouvera sur scène grâce à
savoir à tv fil 78 donc le 7 juin au
théâtre de l'européen à paris et vous
serez dès la rentrée septembre royal
falla royal factory et voilà je désire
elle que je débarque à versailles et
puis entre temps évidemment il ya plein
ya plein d'autres dates
mais ça on reviendra vous le dire
exactement vous n'avez pas fini parce
que les silver année c'est comment
laisser une trace de soi sur sept plats
mais les choix qui aucun ceci vous avez
laissé une porte
je vous remercie merci d'avoir accepté
notre association ça a été un plaisir de
vous recevoir et revenez quand vous le
souhaitez mais je restais moi très bien
précis alors après une première session
de stage d'une semaine sur les listes
l'ancien du projet back et to africa dif
radia reviennent au prisme cette semaine
pour s'approprier le langage gestuel de
la pièce la restitution de l'atelier est
prévue le 1er octobre
back to africa ou la rencontre de deux
univers musicaux
un métissage entre musique
traditionnelle gabonaise et musique
classique il fera via propose une
relecture de cette pièce lors d'un
atelier de danse mené au prisme
d'elancourt toute cette semaine une
quinzaine de danseurs confirmés y
participent
le point de départ en fait c'est tout
c'est une pièce qui a été écrite en 1996
et qui a été créée ici au prisme au sein
de la compagnie black blanc beur et donc
vingt ans après c'est une relecture de
cette pièce par des danseurs amateurs
des danseurs du territoire
cette pièce elle est plutôt focalisés
sur le corps ce que ça pour exprimer ce
qu'ils aiment et ce qu'ils rejettent ce
qu'ils n'acceptent n'accepte pas laisser
de revisiter sa
en 2016 quoi avec les gestuelles
d'aujourd'hui les danses d'aujourd'hui
le regard des gens d'aujourd'hui pour
revisiter la pièce de façon plus
contemporaine il faut accélérer le
rythme de la chorégraphie selon les
danseurs de l'école de danse de la ferme
le genou saudel en cours et ceux de la
compagnie de maria mendy de guyancourt
c'est l'objet de la deuxième session de
l'atelier dif radia ce que j'aime chez
lui c'est son style la façon qui va
prendre les choses et la façon du
travail au sol aussi les cra fait que
s'amplifier
sa simplicité ses gestes ses mouvements
gracieux
il a son style à lui est là en avis
extérieur qui nous emmène loin par
rapport à ce qu'on fait d'habitude quand
même pas aussi retrouvez aussi toutes
les danses du monde comme le hip hop
classique le mode ndiaye
si on peut appeler ça du pop
intelligente une troisième session aura
lieu en septembre pour permettre aux
danseurs du projet back to africa de
terminer le processus de création
la représentation du spectacle est prévu
devant le public du prix ce modèle en
cours le 1er octobre prochain et on va
dès à présent ouvrir une page sculpture
avec vous nicolas sanhes bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation à la
rencontre vous plaisant nous présente
plus parce que vous êtes un acteur
important sur le territoire où vous
connais on connaît votre travail aussi
bien sûr trappe que la verrière mais
pour ceux qui ne vous connaîtraient pas
vous êtes originaire de rodez vous avez
fait les beaux-arts de perpignan et donc
vous êtes venu vous installer sur saint
quentin en yvelines avec votre atelier
en 1997
samedi 30 avril vous proposez une visite
de votre atelier
expliquez-nous un peu le déroulement de
cette visite alors c'est par une
mutation du musée de la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines qui m'ont demandé de
recevoir du public ce que je suis allée
plaisir bien entendu alors ça va être
quelque chose d'assez simple à 1h30 on
va pouvoir parler d'un peu de travail et
d'expliquer un petit peu le déroulement
du fil ou de la construction de la ligne
qui est identique identifiables par mon
travail parce que justement on va en
parler parce que vous avez démarré vous
par la peinture
votre travail a par la suite évolué vers
la sculpture jusqu'à obtenu justement
cette marque de fabrique cette signature
ce que vous appelez cette ligne ainsi
d'autres comment est ce que vous êtes
arrivé à celle ci et là alors c'est un
processus c'est un processus d'analysé
de forme de prise le temps de réflexion
de voir un peu comment les choses ça
s'articule c'est des processus de
travail qui amène
dans une phase à une autre et dans une
technique à une autre et puis cette
observation de d'une forme de logiciels
a chuté de d'extraire des lignes puisque
de voir comment ils sont et on sait tous
que des lignes sont fait ce sont une
juxtaposition de deux points
hélas le matériau à imposer une autre
forme
une autre conception de la mise en deux
lacs de lave de la halle de la de
l'allier mad men et du coup voilà alors
cette ligne justement vous la fait
évoluer vous la déforment et voulait
développer et elle est blanche ce qui
peut interpeller parce que vous avez
travaillé en fait on travaille en
goudron donc le noir pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez souhaité justement que cette
ville est ainsi dentelle soie blanche à
chaque fois alors le goudron ça fait
très longtemps ça fait parce qu'à 30 ans
donc du coup il y avait un espace de
temps qui c'est qui c'est qui va dire
par l'opposition oui on peut y voir une
sorte de position mais ça peut être
aussi alors je veux pas faire une
comparaison qu'il se répète qu'on peut
trop prétentieuse mais c'est pas ça bien
sous là je parle de la lumière dans le
noir donc là on est loin de là bien
entendu mais c'est parce que la ligne le
blanc donne à la densité de la matière
une légèreté qui augmente doucement la
dualité de la densité de la sculpture et
de sa légèreté alors ça reste très léger
et pourtant en fait non pas pourtant
ailleurs c'est pas une opposition mais
vous évoluer vers de la sculpture
monumentale cette ligne là vous vous
l'agrandissent et au maximum jusqu'à
essayer justement les points de rupture
les contraintes techniques de la serre
et que l'équipe d'algérie
c'est ça alors là c'est moi je ne ferais
aucune équipe d'ingénieurs de systran
d'ailleurs ceux qui au petit qui pense
le métro certains 2018 donc là étudiés
chez lui avec eux la capacité de pouvoir
comment pousser repousser les limites
parce que pour moi la sculpture c'est
déjouer les limites physiques et
et pas sic bien entendu est donc là on
réfléchira faire des pièces assez
importante 10 15 mètres de haut et ses
sculptures monumentales d'ailleurs vous
allez les annuaires rodez rodez jusqu'au
mois d'octobre au musée soulage dans le
jardin du musée sous la joue je vais
présenter trois grands de pièces mais et
le sud trésor
alors justement les gens qui veulent
découvrir votre travail de façon un
petit peu plus approfondie pourront se
rendre à la visite de votre atelier
samedi 30 avril les inscriptions se font
sur le site du kiosque à l'adresse qui
s'affiche à l'écran
merci nicolas sanhes d'avoir été en
plateau avec nous et donc la visite
samedi 30 avril
on passe maintenant tout de suite à
l'agenda culturel quelques dates pour
vous idée sortie mercredi 4 mai 16h
retrouvez le monde sous les flaques une
pièce de théâtre jeune public le
professeur armand qu'invite un voyageur
de flacq à nous parler de ces mondes
alternatifs qui existe sous nos pieds
mercredi 4 mai 20h30 direction la
batterie de guillot cours pour retrouver
le trio formé par le grand
contrebassiste de jazz à vis à vis chahi
cohen le pianiste daniel d'or et omri
mor à la batterie on écoute un extrait
à
et enfin au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines mercredi 4 mai
20h30 toujours retrouver la pièce de
théâtre la trilogie dû revoir à
l'occasion d'une exposition qu'ils ne
verront pas les personnages de botho
strauss mis en scène par benjamin port
et nous tendent un miroir et pose une
question cruciale comment vivre ensemble
et c'est la fin de cette émission que
vous pourrez voir et revoir sur notre
site internet
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée